[Music]
Hey
REO welcome man Matt Schaefer welcome
hey Beth I have an hour before before I
need to go to the dentist and I decided
to accept some challenges on Twitch
having streamed chess on twitching like
well I'm like two and a half years so
even you yeah if any of you guys are
interested in a game just drop a
challenge on leeches quois alright we
have a we have a challenge from quois
what am i drinking or just just normal
water alright boys best of luck to you
sir
yeah no not rakia but but I could also
drink rakia before the dentist I don't
think he'd mind is cause here an
equivalent he welcome ah he's here
alright this is the first game so we're
gonna go for the for the Scandinavian
let me just fix that a little bit I
think there's like a double sound okay
I've switched some some sounds in
animation so I needed I needed to lose
the the dancing and the people song that
was playing when someone subscribed as
when I tried uploading the video on
YouTube it immediately
well it didn't receive either received a
copyright strike but I I couldn't upload
it like normally ah and I need to shift
yeah these browser sorry it will only
take a second I need to shift some of
them here paste this here paste this
just a second
paste this here there we go
and another one copy
and paste this here sorry always forget
to do this yeah but now I think we're
good now
all right so we're gonna go Bishop g4
now we've spent some time but it's cool
yeah always problem with the music on
YouTube okay so he he goes for this
trade I don't mind
do I mind I don't mind
hey Sammy Sammy welcomes on me we want
to go 'if Ivan somehow Castle queenside
but it's a very slow game so we might
even be castling kingside we'll see have
ever faced a cheater yeah but you you
get you get your rating points back
after you place a cheater okay I'm gonna
just go here and then now I have a
threat so we'll see we'll see what
happens
Davi eleven unwelcome man hey Anu
welcome I pity the great welcome man
okay so now he defended the bishop but
we're trying we're gonna try and kick
away the Queen from the defense of the
bishop okay he still he's still going at
it yeah this this does make sense yeah
I'm just gonna move back the Queen so I
can play like g5 something like this and
castle he doesn't have any any good
squares for the night we're gonna
capture play this and go here I guess I
don't know I don't like my position all
that much but it's one of the the
weirder ones I've played in the
Scandinavian that is Alice forty four uh
are all the emotes are here nice I guess
I capture here first
and now he captures with the bishop I
saw in a night move and then I
recaptured probably I don't know we
messed something up here yes to tongue
is very funny hey Tony Ponyo welcome man
Oh meadow meadow him oats are here nice
ok let's capture that so we're not
castling oh he didn't want to get that
that's a little bit weird I guess but ok
maybe not that weird what's he planning
to do I'm gonna capture this with my
queen ok he wants to check made me can
we can we stop this even can we must
stop this checkmate it's crazy
oh yeah
not easy oh yeah we're getting
checkmated here almost for sure no not
really we we've made an escape route but
it was quite quite dangerous but he's
very long time a fizzbuzz pause welcome
man meadow in Portuguese means fear you
don't say that's wild vegan blunt warp
hey man alright so we escaped death by
Baja by a marked by a very small margin
here keyboard warrior welcome man ok so
he captures I'm gonna capture and allow
this check which doesn't do all what's
this this is weird there there's no
actual threat here so we're just gonna
we're just gonna what make a rock lift
and get the rock into the defense as
well yeah I will I will capture that I
mean ok but he lost some time but it was
very close if I didn't have this square
for my king it'd be it'd be pretty crazy
a win-win scepter welcome man what is
this game oh it's it's really an ancient
game do I play followers I play
exclusively followers I only play
followers just challenge me on leeches
and you can play a game but maybe make
it a three plus so okay here's a five
plus so I will accept this one but made
me make it a three plus all for the for
the next ones okay let's try something
that I don't usually play spike are we
welcome man
okay so very quickly accepted I like it
let's go here okay
he really he's really going after the d5
square yeah we will take that create a
passed pawn and what now
now go here keep an eye on that let's
just castle here nicely and I guess we
move the bishop and place c4 to make
this pawn very solid unless he goes b5
now he's going b6 okay I'm gonna go
Bishop e7 we're gonna go rook c1 and
shift our
Sanyal and welcome and congratulations
on becoming excellent dream sniping
doesn't work okay he didn't fall for my
trick here but I didn't expect him to do
it to fall for it so all's well I have a
very nice pawn here probably gonna try
and do something along this diagonal
just just try and make him create some
weaknesses I guess Messiah did NASA
invent
understorms to cover up the sound of
space battles I I doubt it as there's no
sound in space s Arvind welcome man yeah
sounds like a stretch sounds like a
stretch okay so he's I guess he is not
finding any moves I mean you can always
play some like h6 force me to to decide
what to do with the distance I can't
really go here and okay he's preparing
to double up he's preparing to double up
so we're just gonna we're just gonna do
what f4 seems like a reasonable move
here since he cannot capture and we well
we wouldn't mind capturing this okay
we're gonna go f5 as well since we
really wanted this I allowed him to
create a passed pawn but now he has to
worry about this and also captures
followed by character so I'm not really
worried ah he wants to he wants to get
it to the e5 okay let's just force him
to get a nice to e5 and nicely capture
here I mean that's pretty reasonable I
would say force him to get rid of the
knight
we captured this is defended
and Arno looks very very ef6 I mean if
you if you have to play f6 I'm not I'm
not convinced let's just develop and see
what happens
yeah he doesn't have any Knight f3
action alright I guess we'll double up
on the C file as well okay that's a nice
check I will not allow it and now we
just double up and he has to be very
careful his King is on the same diagonal
so if he does something weird like
Queenie 7 yeah I guess we just win here
really right like we attack and then he
captures with the Queen I play c5 check
and it's winning
I guess should be all right so I guess
c5 check just wins on the spot or or
maybe I'm missing something but I don't
think I am yeah a little bit of chess
today I thought it'd be nice this
doesn't really change anything he does
win the rook but yeah he didn't even
capture so not not much of a not much of
anything I would say yeah I mean we we
can just leave this guy here and play
something like this
[Music]
yeah okay makes sense let's go for a
check check here
so we guarded this guy and then we just
push the pawn right let's push the pawn
and that's how we do it
get away fly we're not worried about the
bishop because we can just check and
pick it up so it's not really not really
a problem and I will just up a queen so
there's no real real danger here oh
you're holy Amedeo thanks man
yeah it's good to be online although
it's a this is a very short stream yeah
I can even capture that with the Queen
but I'm not going to no no reason to
make my life difficult yeah let's just
check here and bring the other rook into
the game and that's it yeah there we go
he will now start pushing pawns as
there's not much else to do okay or or
resign but good game man
let me just check if there are other
challenges if there aren't we're gonna
play a rematch but there are alright
Oh Lola lips 5+5 that's too much a funny
witty funny with your mom welcome man
alright first one is three plus oh okay
gains gains with three plus so Omega not
let me just shift those animations to
another corner yeah let's switch that
here next our good friend Misha there we
go alright so we enjoyed our previous
Scandinavian okay so he pre moves this
Jackie we saw welcome man who will I be
playing Goldeneye someday I I sure I
sure hope so
[Music]
do I only plan leeches
ah well mostly mostly yeah but if you
guys are I mean if you guys are
interested at some point I don't mind
making let's play III I mean just for
fun see what happens
I don't mind trading Queens right away
yeah it's really weird line okay he's
defending it I'm gonna defend it as well
he doesn't want to capture I don't mind
but what's happening with the knight
once I play h6 that's the question
yeah nothing really nothing really yeah
I'm keeping that thank you
I don't support any clubs like not
[Music]
welcome welcome and congratulations on
becoming excellent alright so what do we
have here let's bring our knight into
the game hopefully here this Bishop is
Oakland weird
okay he's attacking our rook yeah he can
never Castle if okay that's just weird
that's a weird square for the Queen that
is weird
so now we're threatening all sorts of
stuff and yeah he couldn't do that but
now let's let's try and force something
maybe not the greatest of characters but
I do get this check ha very very happy
to get one little check in yeah but this
is really a problem for white here III
imagined
yeah that's not gonna do much we're just
gonna go here okay that's matin one good
game mister mister quince play better
I will try man I will
I really am sorry fruit snack doing well
man tips on how to beat high rated
players you must play better moves arch
doggy welcome man are there are there
any other challenges okay I usually
don't like challenges with increment I
prefer like either a three plus so or
lower I don't play a more than five plus
more than three plus so on stream
because the games are just too long yeah
I hope everything goes well with my
surgery as well how often do I plan on
streaming well this will actually be a
very short stream since I have to go to
the dentist I don't know if Mickey
Bonneville is here mahtim are all
welcome man
[Music]
boom boom tnt whitey all right I don't
think Mickey Bonneville is here no he
just he just arrived okay he's here
let's let's see what's what's happening
alright so we'll try and get him to
capture here before we develop the best
shot although he doesn't seem to be
interested yeah let's go a four let's go
here he's gonna play B six I imagine
but you're not now I guess we we could
even capture I don't know I have no idea
we're just gonna wait and see what he
plays okay he's going after my c3 pawn
so Queen c2 I guess it's nice yeah we're
not interested in capturing this well at
least I don't think we are what do I
think about uh Nisha's stream I I don't
know I haven't seen it I only I've only
seen the first one where he where he
just started streaming okay immediately
going for the center that's actually
very good so I'm just gonna play Bishop
e2 it's not not too active but not not
like not active at all okay so what
happens if captures he captures I
capture on c6 is there anything for him
is that uh is that a free pawn is it
captures Knight captures pawn captures I
have no idea no it's not he captures
with the knight and then we just
exchange everything and then I lose the
exchange after Knight captures on c3 but
he missed it so he still wins the
exchange so that's good for him I I'm
the one that missed that one yeah
there's been a free pawn on b7 for a
while that it oh he gives up the Queen
for some reason good Wow
that is that's a fair question
all right we we really yeah positional
queen sacrifice I think we we lucked out
on this one yeah we're just gonna
capture here there's nothing really
happening here captures captures and
yeah okay now we're just up a queen so
why is the fourth completely wrong
what's a full no I didn't I didn't
stream that bullet session I'm sorry
field of view why is it why what's wrong
with the field of view okay so we're
still playing this I guess let's go here
yeah Queens are overrated ah yeah I
imagine I imagine you flagged me well I
run 26 welcome man and dusty the cat
dusty the cat also welcome all right so
this is game over now since he won't
have to give up a rook or no not even
that that's that's it
you've been throwing away your queen
every game and no luck so far
oh wacky weird or welcome man
yes dofus alright let's see if we have
another one
three plus so is best our brunner is
here we have to accept a challenge from
Bruno all right Bruno he's going for his
whatever that is
alright I'm gonna go see three just in
case
okay so this is this is very good for
black and I don't know how to play it
with white but I don't mind we're just
gonna Castle to safety and see how Bruno
will will try to sneak up on us let's go
here yeah okay night is coming five Ivan
I imagine but we're just gonna prevent
him from doing that we're just gonna
prevent him and yeah how do we develop
the night let's say well not there
obviously awesome awesome meter meter
[ __ ] welcome let's go here and we'll we
still have to figure out what Bruno is
doing with the night here he has to play
some like King h8 what is that okay so
he's he's trying to go after the point
but is the queen really useful there
he's gonna play a five or something I
don't buy it I don't buy it Bruno I'm
not saying you're making it up I'm just
saying I don't buy it
marvelous welcome marvelous
Bishop g2 me maybe better maybe but this
way I can shift the rook and also get
some bishop action here on the Queen I
don't know yeah he's going he's going
for f6 he wants to bust open the
position so I imagine we yeah that's
that's a good move
it's a good move but I'm gonna try
something I'm gonna try something weird
here I'm gonna try something like this
grab the pawn and create a passed pawn
here it's not much but I prefer to keep
the position closed and now he is Knight
is pretty much stuck there and well I do
have a pad I do have to pass pawn so
once I move the bishop I start pushing
this point I think this is I think this
could be like a good sacrifice just slow
down his attack but Bruno's a sneaky
player he he will find a way out of this
only gambito welcome why does the follow
sound appear in some of the YouTube
videos that that is weird I have no idea
alright so the knight is not all that
impressive now we're just gonna move it
and push this pawn yeah we're gonna push
that he's gonna go to e5 which we don't
really mind yeah we're just gonna go
Bishop f4 to g3 whoa yeah he's in no
rush to actually move that which is
interesting so we're just gonna advance
the pawn I guess what's happening here
Bruno why are you doing this man let's
just play Queen f3 to g3 and then our
and then our pawns are strong if he goes
ninety five I can just exchange Queens
here I don't need the Queen's on the
board
I belong yeah I did blunder this guy
here so that could be a little bit of an
issue yeah
h4 yeah okay he does get this square for
the night but still let's go here oh and
I just know he doesn't have Roxy to it'd
be it'd be pretty awful if he had Roxy -
yeah he doesn't want to allow this so
let's just force this trade and now we
can push the pawn no we can't Bruno the
Beast he sees everything yeah not
allowing me a lot but that's cool that's
cool
[Music]
oh he's going after that one oh that's
pretty good yeah that's pretty good
and we don't have a way to defend that
Bruno you sneaky weasel
okay we've defended that one and yeah we
don't want to okay I just resigned here
I just resigned here good game Bruno so
I think maybe the the sacrifice was good
but maybe the continued continuation was
the best too hasty maybe not push the
points like like so quickly but good
good game Bruno definitely definitely a
good one Yoshiki yeah Bruno is a beast
if you've seen him play in the Friday
arenas Bruno is always like in the top
ten yeah we don't say in the spirit of
of Misha if we're only if we're only d4
what what if we're only drinking water
yeah but I did I did get the tile
emultion all right so what do we have
here he is very reluctant to accept our
second horn so we're either gonna force
him or we're gonna capture it back both
both is fine for us unless he plays
Knight here then we're just very very
sad all right now we're now we're good
it's a very lame opening I'm using with
black it's not even an opening now but
if if the opponent is not careful good
things can happen and now we just do
what exactly
yeah there's not not a lot we can do
here yeah that is a bit sad that is a
bit sad and now yeah this is this is
pretty bad actually we're just gonna get
the bishop in and like Castle queenside
yeah we're not gonna try this on stream
anymore yeah obviously obviously blush
should be seven and queenside castle a
[Music]
cap 2012 welcome man welcome to some not
premium zelda action this is the most
premium chess action dark chess welcome
man alright so we're gonna go here and
now we can do some discoveries with the
knife as the Queen is not very
impressive here do I also play Zelda I
have played Zelda from time to time ok
so now he's teasing me to go for a
discovery which I will do and we'll see
what happens hmm that's a queen blunder
alright third game we win a queen in a
row except with bruno of course
am I gonna play four-player chest with a
car and Levi maybe maybe I don't know if
they're if they're missing a fourth and
they invite me your she cook Yoshihiko
well congratulations man good game
rather blocky
welcome to the show man all right we
have a candidate master shock shock
shock and Toby let's let's try this one
all right of course the French a French
is great the the immediate 97 I'm not
familiar with that so I'm just gonna
continue like like nothing is happening
yeah of course now we now we kind of
transpose but even that okay is that
playable very well and the 96 yeah okay
I'm very interested in seeing this
[Music]
yeah we have to capture this but we kind
of yeah we have to capture now oh yeah
and he has d4 that's the point okay
okay fair and square fair and square you
want to pawn that's that's fair
alright so now we have to suffer suffer
with with being a pawn down have to open
some lines at least let's go yeah we
can't go there can't go there
unfortunately now we can go here like
maybe try and try and capture this with
the with the rook at least
yeah we're not we're not gaining the
seventh rank okay he captures I thought
he was gonna go to e6 the guard is but
he doesn't care he's up upon let's go
let's go further yeah let's go here
94 check forces me to give up a bishop
[Music]
yeah not not the greatest of positions
and our rook is very very silly there
yeah that is that is interesting I'm not
gonna trade just yet but yeah then he
has this if I don't so I will do it and
see what happens
yeah g5 I guess is good g5 is good and
if he goes after the phone we can at
least win this one yeah if this I we are
gonna go after this point I guess so
he's better but our pawn is maybe less
obstructed it's gonna be it's gonna be
very very tough ya know in a position
like this no the night the night reigns
supreme
solid squirrel welcome man hey Bruno see
you later man
so he's gonna go for a pawn push right
away yeah I guess that makes sense he's
and he wants to block this with with
this and we're just gonna go after this
check
yeah I'm even gonna play this so I'm
hoping kinda to get this in but no now
it's check and now we're gonna pick up
this one yeah it's pretty crazy I'm
gonna play g3 just the first try and
force him away from this pawn although
it's not not gonna be easy I'm gonna try
this yeah check and this there we go
we're still ahead here I believe let's
push the pawn and yeah I mean I'm pretty
sure it's winning unless it's not so
let's let's give one check here yeah
it's gonna be yeah maybe this was one
unnecessary trick yeah I think it I
think this was one unnecessary trick
yeah he's gonna capture this I'm gonna
capture that buddy okay it's still
winning guy my route completely cuts off
his skin from the defense of the pawn
yeah I was just worried a bit too much
for nothing yeah it's winning unless
it's not how did black blue this well we
we put up a stubborn defense that's base
Liat okay so yeah I don't think that
does anything really and this is just
winning for us because this is check and
now we just get our pawn in okay we have
46 seconds and he wants the flag ass
that's very interesting
there we go and meet good job man
was very very intense yeah now it's easy
alright what's the time I have to I I
shouldn't miss my appointment with my
dentist Dark Knight
welcome Dark Knight yeah i blundered
that pawn like terribly and and then i
just tried
III wasn't afraid of a rook ending but
then he forced the rook ending and it
turned out it turned out well yeah it is
going to be tres clean but i only had
like an hour i
let's go for cecilia i only had an hour
before I have to go to the dentist and
it's not enough to play Zelda it's
really not like it took me two and a
half hours yesterday to the sugar the c4
so he doesn't want to play the the
normal stuff okay I'm not a fan of the
normal stuff myself will I stream after
the dentist appointment I don't know I
don't know how long it will take
I'm probably removing my bracers today
so we'll see how long it takes a turtle
man welcome Chuck shining welcome shiny
9
drama don't welcome ok so I'm for some
reason I'm shy about the d5 but I really
shouldn't be I mean we we kind of want
to play that since all since always he
can win a pawn here but he's not going
to for some reason yeah turtle you are
following us again how are you following
us twice that's really weird man
Putney pawn welcome of the pawn and
hello to you as well
eins why oh oh one welcome man
how are how are so many people following
us all at once that's really weird
ah he owns the shell account 31 Jaybirds
welcome
ah he's going for this yeah that's not
good it's not good
cuz we're gonna yeah we're gonna capture
that ah you think it's because the
channel it's because it is the chess
category yeah dirty flag welcome man
that's a good handle ok so we just go
back and we don't really care we're up a
piece so the life is good or awesome
Milano
hello to you hello to you alright so we
capture and should be fairly
straightforward now like Bishop g4 night
here and it's it's a game unless he like
really prevents that signior welcome
took mere alright so this is now a very
very quick very quick goal mr. poppy
butthole oh it's poopy butthole
well welcome sir
ah yeah we go for that no future podcast
will not be on twitch like maybe maybe
sometimes in the distant future if I
will stream them live but I'm pretty
sure they're there are they are going to
be on YouTube yeah but I did I decided
to grow the twitch fan base at least at
least a little bit so you know if
something like that happens in the
future we can always you know be safe
what's my opinion on three dogs vs.
leeches I guess you were trying to put a
link there and it didn't work okay so
like quickest way is this and the night
can just remain there forever or just
this yeah
there's no there's no stopping that okay
eat I welcome eat I okay
[Music]
three dots is the best chess website of
all yeah the three dots yeah I know it
is I know it is well I mean I always say
every website has its has its fair share
of good stuff but for for just gameplay
I do believe leeches is is the best all
right let's challenge that white queen
forever in potato black I didn't really
get that all right so we are probably
worse position wise but we are better
untime so there's that all right he's
going for this one
and also he decided to give up the d4
pawn which is brave definitely and I
don't know if I can allow him to capture
that I will allow him to capture this
I'm not familiar with the with these
Scandinavians were a white place like
weird moves I mean they're not weird a
lot of people play this I just I'm just
not familiar with it
yes activity beats pawn grabbing yeah he
wants to get our Knight away from there
so yeah he's trying to trying to do
something here so I can go this captures
check King moves somewhere on the on the
dark square how about we just castle
here and we laugh at his face yeah I
think that's I think that's the stuff
because if he captures there's like mate
here so that's nice although he can play
f3 but then the knight comes here oh
this is getting this is becoming way too
complicated yeah now now we cannot allow
the capture anymore so I guess we will
not be
the one the ones laughing at his face
we're just gonna trade Queens here and
say okay we're we're better on time
maybe this is playable and if nothing we
can just like enjoy our extra time yeah
he's not interested in that
either he really wants to open up this
file which is which is great I would say
definitely great yeah now we now we lose
this pawn
ah so it's not as great as we've thought
all right we need we need something here
but there's nothing for us here huh
yeah I guess we have to give him that
there's no way around it yeah we lose
this point that it's the there was no
way around that
yeah so I guess it is it is good for him
yeah okay he's he's definitely not in
time to to get the other rook here so at
least that is what makes me somewhat
happy and we can like deliver a nice
check here or maybe even just go Bishop
here yeah but first things first
first things first let's open up this
rook
I mean without that we got nothing all
right we go here now it's getting very
dangerous I don't know for who but it's
getting very dangerous like some some
captures are about to happen I have no
idea where he's going let's let's go
here just try and grab some space
oh he castles that makes sense yeah
that's what anyone would do I guess
yeah let's capture we not pawn back and
enjoy our extra time I guess yeah 93
we're not capturing that this is nice I
would say so yeah c5 yeah he can double
up now but now was that a free night no
it wasn't yeah I'm just imagining things
yes let's go back like not all the way
back yeah or maybe even all the way back
yeah not interested in that captures and
night check picks of the bishop maybe
maybe does maybe does oh nice nice
I was hoping and tricking him with so
little time on the clock but at least we
do we win something here yeah we win
something but it's not much we will win
on time however because six seconds is
not enough to play this position but
yeah we can even capture that capture
here here okay so the good thing is that
we were not doing great
yeah now we push the pawn to victory
there's no way for this night to to
handle that let's go here check and yeah
okay that was that was very intense next
so welcome next okay Turin welcome to
the team
614 yeah we got time I believe we got
time for either one short game now
either one a reasonable game or two
short ones but I think it's gonna be
just one who's been here who's been here
the longest Cobra Cobra Cobra 23 Oscar
tell welcome man alright so we haven't
lost with e5 so we're gonna use that
yeah I'm trying out twitch a little bit
okay not interested in my second pawn
very well sir
why not the nimzo-indian ah well this is
my first stream and chess in a long time
I decided not to go for like the names
all right away that's reasonable yeah
that's reasonable now 95 I have to go
back so he's doing he's playing very
well completely trashing me yeah I can't
even Castle now I have to play I have to
play slow moves like this yeah at least
yeah now that's a free bishop these
notification sounds are completely
completely wasting my attention that I
don't I do not know what this is though
that was a good move however this is
this looks weird okay so he wants the
check made me here I do not like that
idea
okay the bottom all and welcome bought
him on alright and he wants the trade
being down a piece down yeah okay
I guess I guess we can play that so
what's the quickest way to win let's
bring the rooks in and that's pretty
much it yeah I kind of don't want to
lose this one
so let's go back over night [ __ ] and
yeah just sub alert would suffice yeah
okay it's not gonna be like this like
forever moose knuckle
welcome moose knuckle you pulled it
where did you pull it free bishop it has
a free bishop but my bishop is under
attack yeah okay now he's gonna trap my
bishop do so
yeah now it is a free bishop that is
true that is true all right so he's
really going going for me here yeah
let's let's go back all right
defender this guy I guess we go this way
there we go and let's shift our rooks
all the way there okay this is covered
so I'm not really worried about that
let's get the King closer yeah nothing
to worry about here let's shift the
rooks here yeah he's still very tricky
even though there's nothing actually
happening here
all right so create a platform and and
go here yeah that should do it
that should do it okay yeah the game
okay so this was just a very short
stream I decided to test out if chess
was working on twitch a lot of people
say it is but I have to go to the
dentist now so see you guys see you guys
you know probably tomorrow till tomorrow
morning with some with some Zelda and
maybe we'll see whenever I have like an
hour or maybe I wouldn't have something
that's not good you know long enough for
Zelda we're gonna play a few chess games
yeah thanks guys and see you soon